has it been harder on any one of the  three or have they all sort of just my  youngest Marley she's she's bored it's  kind of like a baby thing  she has like night terrors you know it's  you know since I call them out for me  but I'm not they're definitely taking it  hard like whatever I you know that call  call home she's like you know like where  are you like what you want to come home  so she's nothing taking it how do you  handle I just try to say it strong it  hurt it definitely does but for her you  know I just try to you know sound  confident sound strong hey honey you  know I gotta be home so you know be a  big girl for her are you also trying to  show her something yes what do you think  she might burn  when she might learn from you  I think that I think that oh definitely  bills arm strength and independence